هل هل كان التاجر العربي في هذه المناطق
مش فقط يستقبل حركه التجاره او يصدر بعض
بضائع المحليه لا هو بنفسه ينشا محطات
تجاريه في الخارج نعم نعم يعني يذهب الى
هناك بالتالي ينقل معه ثقافته الى مصر الى
سوريا الكبرى الى احد الانباط في عند
النقش نبطي وجود معبد موجود في اليونان في
معبد معبد مما يعني المعبد هذه لماذا يقام
لانه فيه في تكرار للناس اللي يجون حتى
يمارسوا صوت القدس المدينيه في هذا المعبد
او في هذا المسجد يمارس طقوسم الدينيه في
معناته في في حركات تجاريه والعلاقات ما
بين الانباط وروما علاقات قويه جدا يعني
احيانا طبعا فيها نوع من التبعيه لكنها
ايضا فيها نوع من همم
تبين حقيقه دور
الثقافي يعني عند الانباط الحقيقي
معين ساج موجوده كلها في حضارات حضارات
قصدي يعني مجتمعات ومراكز حضاريه لها
احتكاك كبير جدا مع مع المناطق خارج
الجزيره العربيه وداخلها ال- ال- هي
المشكله عندنا يعني من انه الناس لا لا
يتصورون انه الجزيره العربيه بصحرائها
اليوم انها كان انتجت مثل هذا المنتج وهذا
الخطا اللي لقائنا فيه طبعا نحن في اقسام
في تخصص الاثار لم يعطي هذه الاثار حقها
وفي نفس الوقت نحتاج الى دعم